hey I'm Mark Wahlberg and I'm Kevin Hart
and we're back with the wired complete
interview no it's the wired auto
complete interview
complete yes you don't listen it's your
problem man
[Music]
what is Kevin Hart's best movie
um
I'm gonna have to say me time is Kevin
Hart the Kev of the king of comedy I
can't answer that question uh oh I would
never say that I am the king of comedy
is Richard choir pretty much said it was
ready uh Dave Chappelle it's your father
language you know I would say that
there's so many before me that paved the
way for me to do what I did
why did Kevin Hart start acting well
shouldn't be when is he going to start
okay no that's not that's not guys don't
laugh at that don't don't laugh at that
why did Kevin Hart start acting I don't
know why did you because you wasn't
gonna make it an ambient
you peaked the NBA entertainment league
and you're like oh [ __ ] they got to do
something else it's because this door
was open and I said why not try to run
through it I saw an opportunity comedy
opens up doors this was one of them all
right that's amazing okay what movie is
Kevin Hart and Ice Cube in oh [ __ ] I
know that oh that's the one where he
drags you that's another guy that I know
that made you look good yeah
it's right along man
who does Kevin Hart playing Super Pets
this is coming out this is coming out of
like a week and a half you should know
this answer hey I play ace Chihuahua no
it's a big dog it's a Hound a big one
yes it's a big dog I'm a I'm a big
stronger who set Kevin Hart up in true
story oh I didn't see that it was Wesley
well you just answered it there you go
by the way way to spoil the movie in the
show for everybody else to watch it
jackass
how many movies Mark Wahlberg played in
Mark Robert I don't know 50 so no he's
been in at least 63 movies
is that really yeah I was one off
look at that I know you buddy it's
Entourage about Mark Wahlberg uh
absolutely that's about Mark and his
crew uh actually the originator of a
crew in Hollywood stems from Mark
Wahlberg and his loyalty to his crewing
guys shout out to him for being one of
the first a movie where Mark knows
everything I mean what I'll be picking
just one here I'll be talking about
onset or offset that I know everything
how would you not know that
because that was the 64th movie
you had two okay was Mark Wahlberg
a rat in the department yes no I was I
know you were Capital certainly funny no
but some of the cops were right I know
that but I know you weren't I was trying
to be funny Jesus I just said it then he
got mad he didn't care about infinite
but you said something about the party
oh [ __ ] okay
in the rocket oh uh Dick's in the park
what what's it called
Dick's in a park paint again huh pain
again I thought it was the other guys
didn't do a cameo oh he was in the other
guys too that's correct that is correct
he's just doing the game in the opening
yeah
does does Mark Wahlberg really wake up
at 2 A.M no he wakes up at four no you
don't wake up because many times yeah if
I go to bed at six I'm up at two yeah
that's because of gas come on it's not
does Mark over drink coffee I see you
drinking coffee early but I'm supposed
to drinking yeah
what is more call her bench press
um that's easy lightweight um I don't
know probably like 145 150. nothing
crazy got little arms white is more
important wear gloves when he works out
bad wrists and hands and then yeah yeah
that's what it is callus is already bad
enough thank you guys
yes sure
uh guys the reason why Mark Wahlberg had
to leave and I'm now sitting here by
myself it's because I'm the only one who
really cares about their career uh Mark
is at an age now where he has to go to
the bathroom quite often the period of
the day it's called a weak bladder
happens when you pop the age 50. but I
have no fear because I'm here to Soldier
us through all right does Kevin Hart do
his own stunts absolutely that's a
stupid question you've seen my body
everything you see in any movie with me
is a stunt until you see me and it's not
me figure that out does Kevin Hart like
the rock absolutely that's my brother
love him to death life is an
understatement love is really what it is
does Kevin Hart own fabletics yes kind
of question is that I'm an owner of the
brand and I have tons of fabulous
clothing why well because quality and
comfort is best when it's presented to
you at a price point you can afford
fabletics put that for your chest that
was not a commercial Mark has his own
line which is called Municipal which is
a very good line as well looking at two
entrepreneurs so we're guys that believe
that we can do things ourselves
especially attach ourselves a great
opportunities and we both have so shout
out to Mark as well he would tell you
the same thing if he was here
does Kevin Hart like anime
um I don't dislike anime but I've never
watched it so I can't say that I like it
because I've never seen it but my
daughter loves it
shouts out to heaven heaven loves anime
does Kevin Hart really have a
photographic memory absolutely watch
this
this Kevin Hart really have a
photographic memory
that's not photographic I don't know
what it is
right I said a sentence I told you what
the sentence was the sentence before
that one come on I could do it all day I
can run through the list because I
remember it all
right I'll do it next time okay
why is Kevin Hart important well because
people need laughter without laughter
the world sucks
there you go why is Kevin Hart afraid of
animals because animals don't talk
English I don't speak our language I
don't know what you're thinking so why
shouldn't I be afraid you can attack me
whenever you want why is Kevin Hart in
Belfast oh Kevin Hart was in Belfast
filming a movie called lift for Netflix
as well Heist movie directed by my good
friend brother F Kerry gray why did
Kevin Hart voice Kanye West
uh because it was funny it was like it
was a good opportunity it was fun it was
a video and it just made sense I was in
Lil Dicky's Earth video okay I don't
care why is Kevin Hart a comedian
because there were no other options
it was either this or strip I chose
comedy and if like my career stripping
would have been that successful that's
the real deal
all right is Kevin Hart a nice guy
absolutely what kind of question is that
is Kevin Hart an Eagles fan absolutely
Fly Eagles Fly
e-a-g-l-e-s egos
it's Kevin Hart a shark if you're
talking about cards I can be uh if
you're talking about swimming I can be I
don't know in what regards this would be
towards so I'm going to assume you're
talking about cards and swimming in both
yes
it's Kevin Hart taller than Tom Cruise
absolutely and I'm a badass too catch me
in Top Gun six
all right it's Kevin Hart good at
bowling absolutely uh when I used to
bowl actively I probably average like a
175 180. pretty good bowler
hook see that that's what you can tell
somebody that's my fingertips coming out
the ball correctly it's my ball
releasing releasing releasing releasing
let's try
there it is
hope you got to know a little bit about
Mark and myself anything else Mark oh
you just touched upon everything there
you go all right
problem solved nice
[Music]